(cheerful music)
- [Narrator] Blimps,
slower than an airplane,
not very maneuverable, and
a bit on the bulky side,
a relic of the past, right?
Well, not for everyone.
- [Narrator] That's right, blimps.
And Igor has been chasing this very
specific dream for a long time.
- [Narrator] Igor studied
engineering in university,
but starting a blimp
empire in the final throws
of the Soviet Union proved challenging.
- [Narrator] And Igor's
blimp empire grew from there.
Eventually selling surveillance blimps
to governments around the world.
And to be clear, these
state-of-the-art airships
are nothing like the blimps
from the Hindenburg days.
- [Narrator] But in the back of his mind,
there was another goal:
to create something the
world has never seen before,
a cargo airship.
- [Narrator] That's three
football fields long, just to
put it in perspective, and
Igor believes a massive-loading
cargo ship could come in
very handy in a catastrophe.
As seen here in his
own artistic rendering.
- [Narrator] And he says
he's getting really close
to realizing that dream.
But even when his airship takes
to the sky, Igor won't stop.
(lighthearted music)